here's what would happen if you went
through puberty in 24 hours first your
pituitary gland would start spewing out
hormones it would set off a chain
reaction within a few hours hair would
grow on your legs your arms and your
armpits and down there too and to make
matters worse your voice would start to
crack you'd also add up to seven
centimeters of height every 90 minutes
then girls would start getting their
first period and then another one every
seven and a half minutes
their reproductive organs would work so
fast it would cause extreme discomfort
and pain
by the afternoon your body would be
transforming so fast it would consume
all your energy you'd be starving from
your extreme growth spurt and be
extremely sleepy when you finally went
to sleep your growth would start to slow
down welcome to adulthood
so